hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the particularly interesting
discussions that comes up in plato's
dialogue the euthyphro where socrates
and euthyphro
are discussing their cases and the bases
for them
outside the law court where socrates is
about to go on
trial and euthyphro as well
has to do with what is
dear to or what is pleasing to the gods
because
euthyphro is going to eventually define
piety
in terms of or the holy what what is you
know
this religious value in terms of what is
pleasing to the gods
and that's going to bring up some
problems because
if you look at the traditional greek
religion
you find that there are cases where the
gods actually don't agree
on what is pleasing to them what is dear
to them
for example zeus quite clearly likes to
screw around quite a lot on his wife
with all sorts of mortal women
and tends to get them pregnant and then
you know produces little demi-gods like
hercules and
and then hera usually tries to kill them
because hera is not pleased both about
the fact that zeus has cheated on her
and about the fact that some other woman
has had a child
by zeus so you know those are cases
where you can point to quite easily the
entire trojan war you've got
some gods lined up on one side some gods
lined up on another
the same thing goes for the odyssey
where poseidon
um you know he's not happy with with
odysseus to begin with
but then when odysseus manages to pluck
out the eye of his son
and uh tells them hey it's me that did
it
his son prays to him and poseidon now
doesn't want to let odysseus go home
meanwhile athena wants to let him go
home
so we've got this this uh motif that
comes up
over and over again of conflict between
the gods about particular things
and in this case euthyphro is actually
bringing a lawsuit
prosecuting his father and he's
he's you know coming into the court as
the accuser
but he's also coming into the court as
you might say a defendant
in public opinion because everybody's
looking at him and saying
it's wrong for you it's wrong
not only in a way having to do with
justice but in a way having to do with
holiness
for you to be prosecuting your father
and
if he wanted to look at you know classic
examples
zeus takes action against his father his
own father takes action against him
um so there's plenty of precedent there
and euthyphro is drawing on that
socrates is going to point out a big
problem with this
if you're going to say that doing the
right thing the pious thing
is what's pleasing to the gods then when
you've got this greek religion which is
polytheistic that means they have
multiple gods who you know
are in charge of different things and
and no one of which
actually can control the entire
operation
even zeus who's the king of the gods can
be fooled can be circumvented
these are also anthropomorphic gods that
means that they are like human beings
in that they have feelings desires
plans and these are these don't all line
up with each other
socrates then is able to say well this
definition of the pious that you're
giving me is not particularly useful
because what about cases where the gods
actually disagree with each other now
notice how important
this anthropomorphism is
in in dealing with this issue because if
there were multiple gods but they were
unlike human beings let's say they were
more like
bees where there's a queen and the queen
really is in charge of everything
and all the workers you know more or
less are
following her lead whatever that happens
to be we don't really
fully understand how these things work
but just imagine that sort of case
then it wouldn't be that big of a
problem because you wouldn't have
disagreement arising
and if there was disagreement there
would be ways that it could be resolved
but
human beings with human beings in human
affairs disagreement
works somewhat differently as we'll see
in just a moment
so if the gods really are like super
powerful human beings that have
all sorts of you know other attributes
and have been around
for a very long time and get to metal
and human affairs
then they're going to disagree with each
other along the same lines that human
beings do so we can we can figure out
what that's going to be like by looking
at the way that human beings disagree
with each other
socrates brings up two different domains
in which people would find themselves in
disagreement
and one of these is what we might call
the mathematical domain
and we could extend this to include
anything where there's some sort of
decision procedure in place
where there is a clearly defined canon
of how you in fact
take care of these things if we wanted
to think of something more
qualitative and not quantitative we
could think about
cuisine you know chefs actually have you
know when there's a recipe
there's certain things that have to go
into the recipe there's a flavor profile
you taste things quite a bit you can
disagree you know are these
these eggs bad or not does this have
enough cinnamon or not
did you cook this the right way or not
but
you can figure out the answers to that
one person is going to be right and the
other person is going to be wrong
perhaps both are wrong because some
other person is right there's a standard
so in matters like that we can
end up in disagreement but we end up in
disagreement because
somebody has got a mistaken perspective
and that person can be
led to see if they're not you know just
being stubborn or
stupid that they have a mistaken
perspective
so you know i think that my car takes
unleaded
and my friend thinks that it takes
diesel somehow he manages to jam the
diesel into there even though it's not
shaped for that fills it up for a diesel
car doesn't run right
you know i can say look at dummy i told
you it took
unleaded and you know here's the manual
now where can't we do that sort of thing
or where does that break down and
notice the other index that he has where
do we get
super excited passionate
angry even hateful with each other
well it's in what we call
moral matters with numbers if you
think that you know this video is 20
minutes long and i think that it's 10
minutes long we can look at the youtube
uh reading for it or we could look at
the actual raw data and we could say
well it's
this amount of time you're right i'm
wrong or i'm right you're wrong
when it comes to moral matters this
doesn't mean by the way that socrates
thinks this is all up in the air that
nobody's right that everybody's right or
anything like that
he's just saying we do often disagree
about moral matters
what are moral matters the just and the
unjust or sometimes you'll see it
translated as the right and the wrong
the the kion and adico
the good and the bad the agathon and
cocoon and this has a moral sense to it
and there's multiple
ways in which things can be good or bad
in other platonic dialogues you'll often
see him referencing the pleasurable
and the painful usually in order to say
well that's not really what good and bad
means so
what he often means is the advantageous
and the harmful
or just the morally good and bad in a
way that's not
simply reducible to the just and the
unjust
and then we have this other catch-all
category that covers an
awful lot that the greeks did feel to be
the realm of moral qualities and i think
we probably ought to see it that way too
the noble and the base or the beautiful
and the ugly or the honorable and
dishonorable or
shameful the colon and
icecrown and these are the sorts of
things that people do in fact disagree
about
go to any you know
holiday gathering give some people some
some liquor
and throw some controversial issues out
of the table and you're gonna have
people arguing with each other
unless you have extremely well
disciplined people
uh go to thanksgiving you know and see
the student who's come home from college
and now
sees things in a different light than
their parents do
once again we're going to have argument
now what's really interesting about this
and socrates uses the example of a court
of law
as a prime case
disagreement is not so easy to settle
when it comes to these kinds of matters
why not well there isn't
one single decision procedure
or universally recognized standard or
criterion
that we can appeal to like if you know
if we've got a mistake in numbers we've
got
mathematics as a discipline if um
you think that the the
house should go over there and it's in
the middle of a flood plain and the
engineer says not a bad idea
or if you're going to do that you better
get flood insurance
again pretty easy to resolve isn't that
does somebody have a right to build a
house where they want to well you know
we could look at the laws and see what
the laws say but even when we're
applying laws in a very
uh strict and unemotional
you know sort of disinterested sense
there can sometimes be disagreements
about just what the law means
what would actually be the right thing
the just thing in this the situation
but quite often when people are
in some sort of conflict with each other
they
are not seeing eye to eye
not only about whether something is in
fact just or unjust
but oftentimes about what the just and
the unjust
actually are so not just about the
particulars but even about
the general the universal
they may not even have a solid idea
about what the just or the unjust is
and we often do confuse our own
interests for what is just
in other people's for what is unjust
likewise good and bad
when it comes to beautiful or ugly or
think of you know aesthetic
qualities like uh somebody being a
stand-up guy and somebody being a
complete douchebag those would be the
sort of things that would actually fall
under noble and base
for the ancient greeks and
we do have a hard time coming to terms
about these we can provide explanations
we can achieve some sort of consensus
but we very easily do fall into
quite often acrimonious disagreements
conflicts agonistic you know
back and forth arguments about this sort
of thing
so if we can do it the fact that the
gods are conceived
of an anthropomorphic way in a
polytheistic way
means that this can happen with the gods
as well that constitutes a problem
for figuring out just what this is
because
if we're talking about what is pleasing
to the gods
what the gods like what the gods
think has these qualities and not these
qualities
then you're going to get some god saying
i like x
and other gods saying i hate x and
what is a mortal to do then how do you
decide
what actually counts as the holy thing
or the pious thing
to do you're pleasing some gods and
displeasing others
becomes impossible to decide at that
point except in some sort of arbitrary
you know maybe flip a coin or i'll just
go with apollo all the time sort of way
and that clearly is not going to work